welcome ladies and gentlemen let us do
without formal greeting you all die now
hello and welcome to Hunter hunter 101
the series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to be examining
one of the quieter yet simultaneously
explosively charged spiders fate and
Porter fate an Porter is an
overwhelmingly serious man of relatively
short stature who often dons a
predominantly black outfit that covers
the majority of his body his general
demeanor is best described as icy cold
although there are certainly a fair few
layers of complexity hiding underneath
this exterior phaeton grew up in meteor
city a junkyard civilization inhabited
by individuals considered garbage to the
rest of the world here he became one of
the founding members of the Phantom
troupe led by Kronos for a group that
went on to specialize in thievery and
murder throughout the world as an
example one such mission that the group
embarked upon was the systematic
slaughter of the kurt clan in order to
harvest their scarlet eyes which sell
for extraordinarily high prices in the
hunt underworld and as one of the
founding members of the troupe it is
assumed that Phaeton took part in this
event which is quite horrific however
phaeton himself as a particular gruesome
role amongst the troupe as he is their
designated interrogator as a result he
is highly proficient in the practice of
torture and what's more is that Phaeton
seems to greatly enjoy this role
implying a heavily sadistic nature in
fact one of the rare occasions in which
Phaeton will break his icy persona is
when he begins discussing his plans for
interrogating someone such as when the
TripIt capture gone and Phaeton began to
discuss ripping off the bully's
fingernails hmm but that said Phaeton
isn't completely devoid of sympathy even
towards his victims as he has once
commented that the people he feels sorry
for the most are those that are subject
to his torturous ways not sorry enough
to not do it in the first place of
course just enough to perhaps act as a
mildly unpleasant aftertaste after the
deed has been done however fate adds
methodologies do lead him into direct
conflict with our troop members all of
whom are also sadistic murderers in
their own right but even then some of
them still can't quite stomach fate
hence desires other than that as a
founding member fate n gets along very
well with the rest of the troop with him
being quite close to thinks in
particular the two of them will often be
seen on missions together as well as
conducting contests to see who can
murder the most people near that sort of
classic bestfriend behavior it's also
been implied that fate Han has a strong
bond with Sean arc
sting him implicitly even when Shawn
knocks judgment is in stark contrast to
his own but it is also through shall
knock and thinks that we very and I mean
very occasionally see that Phaeton also
wield some sort of sense of humor and is
not above teasing them as indicated by
these sneaky little liars here Phaeton
would first appear in the series during
New york-new arc attending a gathering
of all 13 members of the Phantom troupe
the first have occurred in quite some
time at that point here the group were
charged with stealing an exceptional
amount of merchandise from a mafia
auction role in which Phaeton
demonstrated an affinity for
infiltration as he was able to
successfully disguise himself as an
auctioneer although I don't know I mean
Franklin was also able to pass himself
off as an auctioneer no net number here
but the moment I see this guy pop out is
when my suspicions are going to be
raised so perhaps it was less fate hands
infiltration skills and more the
complete lack of observation by anyone
else in the building that allowed this
mission to succeed however for the rest
of the orc new Ark Phaeton would play
more of a backseat role becoming quite
put off by the presence of kor pika the
last surviving member of the Kota clan
in which Phaeton assumedly took part in
the genocide of and able to match
gripping his mental prowess and
inability is catered specifically to
deal with the true fate and proved
unable to prevent the deaths of over
gain and Paquin oda as well as the
subsequent excommunication of his leader
'the crawler although it should be so
the Phaeton didn't ever receive a fair
chance to actually engage in his
abilities during the york new arc and
sadly that opportunity would have to
wait well and to the events of the
Chimera ant are in a rare display of
philanthropy fate an along with the rest
of the Phantom troupe - crawler returned
to meteo city which was plagued by the
terror of a chimera ant named Zaza who
Phaeton would come to face directly
putting his absolutely terrifying
abilities on display for the first time
first up in terms of hand-to-hand combat
Phaeton favors the use of a double-edged
sheet kumazawa
concealed within an umbrella although
the umbrella portion of the weapon is
not just for concealment purposes as it
can also be open to potentially distract
opponents and is also capable of firing
a bullet through the pressing of a
button on the handle but the use of this
weapon is very much a simple choice in
style for Phaeton as his true danger
comes in the realm of net in terms of
nen Phaeton is a natural transmuter
however he is also highly skilled in the
areas of emission and conjuration the
latter of which is used to construct his
paint pack a hot sue which is a suit of
armor designed entirely to handle
another ability that combines emission
and transmutation known as Rising Sun
with this hot suit Phaeton is able to
transmute his aura into a scorching bowl
of heat like a minute
really and then emit the ball towards
his opponent generally resulting in the
opponent or you know when someone is
actually subject to this technique I
think a better word would be victim in
any case it results in the victim being
helplessly burnt to death meanwhile
phaeton is protected by the pain packer
suit originally conjured which makes him
resistance to the heat as well as
supplies to with oxygen as a kicker
Rising Sun is directly enhanced by the
physical state of fate and himself as
the more damage he has incurred the
longer and hotter rising sun would
become although it should be said that
Phaeton's potential is not simply
limited to this as phynx has implied
that there are multiple variations of
disability and that each begins by
donning a different suit of armor but
the sheer power of the ability we've
seen is not to be underestimated as it
is feared by all troop members who have
experienced it in the past
holding the potential to eviscerate each
and every one of them with ease should
they not escape the blast radius in time
in any case fate and victory over Zossen
awarded him with interim leadership of
the phantom troupe in Crows absurds
however fate town would not hold this
position for long as krohler would
return to the group after successfully
having an exorcism performed on him to
rid himself of Kerekes judgment chain
and now I'd like to flag that we have
some spoilers coming up for non
margaritas it's not a whole lot but if
you really don't want to know anything
at all then please do skip to this time
in the video otherwise let's proceed
currently phaeton is aboard the black
whale one bound for the dark continent
with the rest of the Phantom troupe
simultaneously attempting to steal
treasures of the cockin kingdom must
also seek your revenge against Hisoka
mora the previous troop member
responsible for killing caught topi and
shall knock some more fun facts about
fate an despite being one of the
smallest members of the group Peyton is
considered the fifth physically
strongest member of the troupe according
to the ever accurate measurement of
armwrestling on rare occasions when fate
Han gets particularly angry he will
actually begin speaking an unknown
language which is presumably his mother
tongue although in the anime this
language is portrayed as an inversion of
Japanese in both the manga and anime Fei
10 can be seen reading the works of
Trevor Brown an artist well known for
his exploration of various paraphilia
some of which correlate to fate aunts
own interest in torture and finally a
truly useless fact despite preferring to
hold his sword in his left hand fate an
is in fact ambidextrous but that pretty
much does it for fate and Porter if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the new
worldview patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured or next and hunter 101
you
[Music]